I had been introduced earlier, but my name is Uno and I am the president of Nouvst
Which is a body change personal gym
Thank you for having me today
Thank you
Let's get started then, first, I would like to start with a quick introduction of myself
What I have done in the past
And, after this, if you have questions or things you would like to ask about your body in your daily life
Or if there are general questions you would like to ask
At the end, we've also invited our staff today
For a few minutes, we would like to do a simple demo on how to improve our bodies
Thank you for coming today despite your busy schedule
Let's get right into it then
In 1999
I worked for a big sports club called Konami sports for 15 years
15 to 16 years
Until a little part of this year, I was working there
Has anyone heard of Konami Sports Club here?
I'm glad to hear that
They have about 200 branches, and I worked as an instructor
I started when I was 19
Starting out as a part time, and I became an employee after
I specialized in studio exercises and dance
I may not look it, but I did teach dance exercises
And, bicycle exercises, some of you may be familiar with feel cycle
There are bicycle programs, it isn't exactly feel cycle, but other bicycle programs
These are the programs I handled
And starting in May this year
I opened my own personal gym, a gym that specializes in personal training
That is about my career
Within these experiences
I also introduce myself as a body builder
The reason I started body building
Is because of my twin brother
As you can see in the picture
By the way, I am the one in the left
The right is my younger twin brother
We both worked at Konami sports for over a decade
At the end, we were both in the same store in Musashikosugi
I entered the industry around 2 years earlier
After my brother joined
My brother started body building first
When I started, there were some who were body building
I had an image of them wearing short pants
It wasn't a good impression, so I couldn't find interest in it
But my brother
In 2011
Joined a contest that's become famous for Nakayama Kinikun and Kasuga from Audrey joining
It's the contest called Tokyo Open Body Building Championships
It is sort of the gateway to success for newcomers
My brother, took part 2 years ago in 2009
And out of the blue, he won the competition
And as the fate of twins had come
The people around us started saying that I could do it too because I was the twin
The typical path of the case of twins
There was some time apart
My brother joined in 2009
And 2 years after, in 2011, after avoiding it for sometime
I eventually failed to completely avoid it, I joined the competition in 2011
I eventually was able to have results that proved we were in fact twins
In that year, in the same Tokyo Open division
And, there is also the different weight divisions
In weight divisions in Tokyo, it is in the top classes of competition
I joined them one after the other
And luckily, I managed to win
I started body buildin gin 2011, and in 2012
In body building, the biggest competition is called the All Japan Championship
With divisions other than this, once you win you cannot take part in it again
So, every competition you win levels up, this is the challenging part of it
I kept doing this in a year
In 2014, in "Japan Men's Physique Best Body" which has now become popular
What is different from others is that you have to wear this surf pants
I thought that this would be alright, so I joined it for the first time
From the first All Japan championship
I finished in the 3rd place
Last year, I also took part in the Asian championship
This is the list of contests I've taken part in
It is quite extreme
Compared to those who do not body build
There's a preparation period for the competition, with food and training
There is an extreme difference
By doing this, it spreads my perspective
When I train people on their diet and health maintenance
It really broadens my perspective and knowledge
In this way, I think it was a good experience
With food intake
When you think about the food that body builders eat, what comes to your mind?
Eating a lot of protein
Of course that is not wrong
We do put protein at the center of our diet
Having a balanced food intake is a body builder's diet
Basically, food
For normal people, it may be too strict
For people who have been on diets
It may be a little less strict, and the variety of choice have also expanded
This is something I learned from experience
In terms of the training, it is mostly muscle training
Has anyone here done muscle training before
Muscle training, I think for most body builders
In a week, the days that they do muscle training at the gym is
About 5 to 6 days a week, so that's almost every day
It may be different for people who do normal training
So, they go into the gym, and spend about 1 hour to 2 hours
And, they only work on one part
For example, if it is this arm, they will only do this arm on a particular day
In a week, they are able to train their whole body, this is the kind of training they do
It may be unimaginable for some people
For non body builders, it is not a practical way
There are also many happenings at the competition
Because these trainings can be very strict
So, it might be best to
Get right into the topic that everyone can relate to
Off season, currently, it is the off season
During off season, just like everyone else, we would eat anything and everything
We would also go out and enjoy drinking
Just like everyone else
Just because one is a body builder
It doesn't mean that they are any different, they aren't much different
I would like to take a quick survey
If there are questions or concerns related to it
I would like to help resolve them
So, let's start
We will write down all your questions on the whiteboard
If you tried going on a diet but didn't see results
If you have anything to ask about your body
Please let me know if you have anything
Yes
How much should I control carbohydrates
Do you currently control your carbohydrates?
A little
Let's put carbohydrate control
I'd like to take out some questions that gets asked
And, guide you through using those
Question
My weight fluctuates within the day
I weigh myself once a day
The following day that I eat a lot, for some weird reason my weight is lighter
So, let's put this as the second one
Are there anymore?
My gym trainer often tells me to take protein
In my case, I am worried about chemical additives
How much of artificial things including protein affect our bodies?
Especially when it comes to chemical additives
Do you mean with protein?
That is very specialized
There are quite a few, right? Within those variations
Are there anything else?
I often go to the gym, and I eat a lot
I go to the gym a lot, and I eat a lot, and I take protein too
But I can't seem to gain weight
Hard to gain weight, okay
How thoroughly do you train?
Do you mean in my case?
Yes
And, generally, what is the standard
I also join contests
I work out 5 to 6 times a week, and I lift pretty heavily, but I have a hard time getting muscle pain
In actual, I am becoming bigger, so it might be that I am already used to it but
I am having trouble figuring out if I should put more load into my work out
By the way, what contest do you join
Summer Style Award
I see, that's a pretty high levelled one, fantastic
Are there others? Yes
Sorry, I assume the best way is to go to the gym and train
But, is there anything that can be implemented within a daily life
I think there might be a lot, but if there is something that you recommend, I would like to know
In your normal day to day
Something that you can implement in your daily life
If there are other things that can be done aside from the usual walking and climbing up the stairs
By the way, do you have a particular physical goal in mind?
For example, if you want to improve a stiff shoulder
It could be weight loss
Well, I think both
Both
Is there anything else?
If the goal was to lose weight, what is the ideal ratio for aerobic exercise and muscle training?
It is a bit similar to the question earlier, but if I were to gain muscle, is it best to do aerobic exercises or not?
I think that might be losing weight while still maintaining bulk
That's a very hard-core question
How to lose weight while maintaining bulk
Let's look into each of this
So
First of all
Lately
It has become a fad
To debate about whether carbohydrate control is good or bad, extreme carbohydrate control
It is done even in big personal gyms too
When it comes to diet, there are various ways to do it
If you ask simply if it is good to control or not
Of course, people who do commit to carbohydrate control
Do lose weight and see results
The principle behind this has something to do with the term Ketone body
What this is is, by limiting your carbohydrates
The Keton is released
This has extreme effects in burning fat, simply put, the principle is
When extreme carbohydrate limitations are made
It will be very good for those that can stick to it
Because carbohydrates are simply energy that we use on a daily basis
Energy is converted extremely quickly
These are bread, rice balls, and such foods
Here we have fats that are said to be used for energy, but it is seldom used
By putting extreme limit to carbohydrate intake
The theory is that the Keton is released and it uses the fat to be converted to energy
If you ask whether it's good or bad
When it comes to basics of diet and muscle gain
If it works for you then that's great
But the ideal is to not do anything extreme to avoid rebounds
When I say extreme, when you completely cut carbohydrates then that is quite extreme
It would be very hard
Then when you go back to your old diet
Since there is a large difference
There is this thing called the glucose level when talking about carbohydrates
By consuming carbohydrates your glucose level shoots up
So, if you don't consume any, it goes down, this creates extreme changes
Making the probability of going on a rebound is very high
On the other hand, if you consume a lot of carbs your glucose level goes up, and this is what happens on a normal day
Of course, if you lose this, it would be very hard
So, when I say do not do anything extreme
It is because it is best not to create a gap between these two
I've looked through the diet of many people for the past decade or so
I've witnessed that the probability of success is much greater
So, there are people who can stick to this kind of diet but
There are many that rebound from this
It restricts so much calories, so when you cut your carbohydrates
The diet allows you to eat fat
But the calorie cut from restricting the carbohydrate intake is about 4 calories for 1 gram
So, in one bowl of rice, that is about 200 calories
If you don't eat it for a long period of time, this will reduce the calories
Then, when you try to put that back, the calorie intake simply goes over
Calorie intake and calorie out are the basics of diet
All types of diet boil down to the basics
So, if this simply increases, it will keep increasing
The most effective way not to rebound is
Not to reduce the muscle weight
Of course, when you intake calories, fat intake also increases
And as long as you don't lose the muscle weight, when you want to lose the body fat again this will help
The muscle is like the engine in a car
If the engine is big, when you run the car, it drinks up the gasoline
Gasoline is the energy source
But when the engine is small
No matter how much you run the car
It will not consume the gasoline, because it's a fuel-efficient car
For humans, it is better if it is a gas guzzler
So, it was also mentioned in the question earlier but
The ratio between the muscle training and the aerobic exercise
Even if you do a lot of aerobic exercises
If you do not have muscles, the calories will not burn as much
So, the base is not to lose muscles
When you think about it, going back to the topic earlier, if carbohydrate restrictiion is
Good or bad
Not doing something extreme
Is the best way to continue in the long term
When you see it as it is, it may be good when you want to lose weight in a short period
This is something you can do
There are many theories on this
Is everyone alright?
There was a question about the fluctuation of the weight within the day
When it comes to food intake, is it mostly similar menu and the same amount?
I do cut out rice often in the week
When I tried to eat rice for a day
The following day, my weight reduced
And, the following day, when I eat meat more than usual, my weight had gained
I am confused because I lost more weight when I ate more the day before than on days when I cut carbs
When it comes to weight changes
There are simply patterns, one is increase in body fat
And there is also water weight
When you drink 500 grams of water, you can gain 500 grams of water
So, the fluctuation in weight is normal
There are great fluctuations within the content of your food
One is the water consumption
To intake a lot of water means salt
It is salt, so when you consume too much salt
The water is absorbed into the body
Simply put, the effect is edema or swelling
Especially, for those who work in Google, you are on your computers
The time you spend sitting down is very long
It affects the lower part of your body very much, and it builds up the swelling in your lower body
In addition to this, I also had some of the food served here
You can eat a lot during lunch
Compared to preparing food by yourself, the amount of salt is comparatively high
If you do not control it, to be honest, the salt is very high
The ideal is said to be 4 to 5 grams a day
When you eat out and eat obento from the convenience store
When you consume these, without a doubt you consume 3 to 4 times more of the required amount
When you drink water normally, the water will refuse to flush out of your body
And this will add up to the your weight and pile up
But with in this amount of food, even if the amount of food does not change
When the level or grams of the salt in the seasoning goes over, this also happens
And, since you do desk work for long hours
This would be one of the final reasons
There is the way you sit down on a chair
Depending on the way you sit and your posture, your muscles stiffen
When you work on your computer for a long time, that's is why there were people that had troubles with stiff shoulders
Sitff shoulders occur because the muscles are stiff
Humans have blood vessels
And blood runs through this
When you are on your computer for a long time, our head that usually weighs 5 kilograms
This 5 kilograms leans forward
The weight of this is constantly on here
Then, this part here will be on a constant muscle training using your head
When it stiffens, the blood vessels underneath your muscles
These blood vessels are basically a tube
It crushes it, and as a result the flow becomes bad
This also stops the water from flushing because it crushes the hose
If the flow is bad, it also affects the emission of body waste that
Allows a good blood circulation
If this stagnates
The body fat does not increase but the body weight does increase
On the other hand, if you sweat a lot or if you haven't consumed as much as salt
This would be adjusted
When it is flushed out the body, there are cases that it reduces the weight, it could be this fluctuation
It is very less likley that you will lose 1 kilogram of body fat in a day or 2
To gain 1 kilogram of body fat, that would be about consuming 8000 calories
Is that 8000 kilocalories?
Yes, kilocalories
Can you eat 8000 kilocalories?
I think it is quite impossible
Then, there is also the calories that you burn in a day
A normal adult burns through about 100 calories a day
No matter how much desk work you do, or how much you don't move around, you will burn 1000 calories
When you think about this, a diet that will give you over 8000 calories is impossible
If this goes on a long period for about a week or 2, it builds up, a kilogram increase is possible
But, fluctuations on a daily basis is mainly from water
In controlling water, salt takes up the biggest part of it
I think that is what is happening here
Let's see the next question
Including the suppliment BCA and other chemical additives
To be honest, chemical additives are not good for you
There are many discussions on this but
When you are on a diet, because you do not want to take in calories
The zero calories that you intake in your diet
Includes aspartame and other synthetic sweeteners
But when you think about it in terms of health, it is not good for you
Suppliments such as BCA are often consumed
But BCA is basic amino acid and has a sense of bitterness
To control the taste without adding calories
Most suppliments have them, especially foreign made ones
I would not say it is extremely bad for you
But, if it is just a normal diet, or if it is for health maintenance
You might not need to worry about it too much
But if you compare not taking it to taking it, to be honest
It is not something that is completely healthy for your body
But there is no need to avoid it all completely
If you are very sensitive about these things, there are additive free products being sold lately
It is becoming quite popular, so you can choose to use those
I personally think that there is no reason to be that strict about it
Are we good?
After this, is about not being able to gain weight even after muscle training
By the way
How is your stomach now?
After eating, I feel full
What I am concerned about is that, I eat a lot, but I cannot consume enough
The required calorie intake and such
How is your bathroom situation?
This is quite important
The reason why you do not gain weight is, when you eat a lot, train a lot, and eat more
The food becomes nutrients to your body and especially becomes an ingredient for your muscles
The main source is protein
Is this food being absorbed
And what is most important is wether it is being used as an ingredient to make muscles or not
In figuring this out, the most easy way to decide is
Your bathroom frequency
If you have diarrhea, it means the nutrients are not being absorbed
Do you have diarrhea? Are you okay?
I thought it might be the supplements
It is not the supplements
But the it is about the intestinal environment, when you try to get bigger or you try to eat a lot to gain muscle
When you consume alcohol, things that you do to worsen the intestinal environment
This would also be consuming too much oily food
The intestines end up not functioning
So, when it consumes a lot all at once, it would not absorb it
No matter how much you eat, if it does not get absorbed, this means that it has not become the muscle's ingredient
So, the first thing is, to improve your weight gain
And, this can apply to all of this
It applies to health maintenance, diet, and muscle gian
With the intestines, internal organs, especially the intestines, it is important to make them function welll
How this works is
I will explain this after we answer all the questions, so please wait for that
The training load and muscle strains
Even after training, not experiencing muscle pain
It is hard for me to get them
This also has the same answer to the previous question
There are actually a lot of people who have the same problem
Most people have this problem
The biggest cause of this is
Do you work on the muscle training maching? Do you do free weights? Or is it a mixture?
I do both
Both
The reason you do not get muscle pain is that, it may be that the way you exercise is wrong
But most likely it isn't the case
The biggest cause is the position of your bones
Is not good
Simply put, there is a strain there
It means that your body is not moving the way it is supposed to move
The cause for this is your lifestyle and your work lifestyle
And, as we mentioned earlier, it is also related to the proper functioning of the intestines
There are many who do not get muscle pain anymore
I have been in this industry for 15 to 16 years
When I started out, there were rarely people who did not get muscle pain
There was no one
Now, there are so many
What is the part of your body that least gets muscle pain?
My back
Your back
There are many who do not get muscle pain in their back
And, lately, there are a lot that do not have them on their chests, and the fornt of their arms
The reason for that is because of desk work, computers, and smartphones
Smartphones, we use smartphones very much, and the position of our bones have changed
I assume that you work on a sitting on a chair
For not being able to see the results in training or see the results in dieting
It is because of the strain, but there are 2 major parts
It is the scapula (shoulder bone) and the pelvis
If this is in the original position, the organ's functionanilty also increases
The easiest way this would collapse is when you sit down
When you are seated, your pelvis is position like this
So, your ischium does not stand properly
Either way
Oh, that is the typical sitting position I am talking about
But, we do end up having this position
When we sit for a long time in this position
Our pelvis tilts to the back like this
When it tilts backwards, this part becomes round
Then we have our head that weighs about 5 kilograms
This posture, and you are on your computer
What happens is, the weight of this goes to here
The position of your shoulder goes forward, and you have a hunched back
When this happens you will get stiff shoulders
When you do this for a long period of time, it becomes stiff here
When it gets stiff, of course your blood does not go up, so you start to get headaches, and your neck starts to hurt
These are the symptoms you get
On top of that, if your pelvis tilts backwards like this
You get stress here, and the power of your upper body goes out and keeps going outward
Your belvis starts to spread and spread to the sides
When this happens, the bones on your feet, the thigh bone
Starts to open outward
Then, your pelvis opens
Your internal organs, since your pelvis opens up, it starts to fall down
When it falls down, when the organs were initially in this position, ends up being here
When the functions deteriorates, it stops running
So, we change this posture
This is where your shoulders should really be
On top of your shoulder bones should be the head
Your hip should be parallel to your hip, and this is called the neutral position which is the right posture
Let's try it then
Isn't it hard?
It is hard
If it's hard to maintain this posture and keep your backbone's position
This means that your torso's muscles that maintains this posture is weak
As mentioned earlier, the muscles are the engine, so if it is weak
When tour muscles gets weaker and weaker, your metabolism deteriorates
When you get into this bad posture, the flow deteriorates, and it further worsens
So, if you fix this posture, your intestines will also start to work better
If you don't work on improving this, your muscle training will also not become effective
So when it comes to dieting, gaining muscle, or simply maintaining good health
The conclusion is all the same
The only difference between a body builder and a normal person on a a diet or in maintaining good health is
The volume in the things they do
The number of reps they do and the weight
But the way they do it is the same
What is most important is to correct the body's strain
In the office, standing desks are recommended these days, what do you think of this?
Standing desks are also
Can you stand please
When you stand for a long period of time
You would naturally lean towards either side
If there's a counter in front, you may also lean on it
You can sit down on a chair in the right posture with ease
This is sold on the internet for about 800 Yen
If you have the desk like this
It might not look so good but
Get as close as you can to the desk and your elbow should be
Imagine that the desk is here
And as much as possible
The elbow must be lifted but attached to the desk
As much as possible the ischium should be straight
I think it is hard to grasp how exactly to let it stand straight
You would need the ball here
Can you stand up first?
There is the part that hunches, so you would need to put the ball where it hunches
This is the backrest
In this state, you would lean on the ball when you're sitting down at work
It automatically sets the line here correctly
This chair might be different, but an office chair may be more like this?
I think it stands here more
Then it fits right in
In this position
If you have had bad posture for a while
This would collapse
To know whether the proper posture collapses, the ball will tell you if it falls
If the ball falls out, it means your posture is not correct
You must be able to sit with letting it fall to improve your posture
You must start fixing this first
The reason why your back training doesn't work is because you work on your computer in this posture
Your shoulder bones are like this
When you are on your computer a lot, it becomes like this
With a hunchback, your shoulders come forward, and your shoulder bones is in this position
In this state your back is
This gets slightly technical but
It is this kind of movement, when you do a lot of pull down using your upper body
It has to be this kind of movement
If you have a hunchedback, it will not move when you have your shoulder bones straight like this
You have to start setting it in this position
Or else, no matter how much you train, you will not get muscle pain
It means that you are not able to use it effectively
It doesn't mean that your way of doing it is wrong, but it means that your shoulder bone stands the wrong way
It is the strain in your body
When you start fixing your posture, then you will start to get proper results
Their women especially, their pelvis opens easily
It must be tucked in properly and the shoulder bone should be in the proper position
While you do your training, it is something that actually doesn't get much attention
It is the most common cause of why you don't get muscle pain or your training isn't effective
Can you demonstrate how the elbows should be again please?
Your elbows must be attached to the desk properly
Do you use a mouse?
You don't. It is better if you don't use one.
Usually, the shoulder of the hand that uses the mouse tends to lift up like this
When your elbow lifts up, it means that your arm, though it isn't that heavy
If you keep this for 3, 4, ,or 5 hours
You will use your arm as weights, and it is the same as training it
So, this part gets really stiff
Both sides should be the same height
And you put it on the desk so that you don't use your arm as weights
As much as possible
Put your chair closer to your desk
In the standing posture, it is the standing version of it
The shoulder bone should be aligned to the pelvis and it is ideal if it can be performed in this psoture
So, if you have your computer on a counter
The way you can improve your posture is to
Go very close to the counter
Are we good?
How about using balance balls?
There are many who use balance balls
But balance balls are unstable right?
When you are supposed to sit down with your ischium and both hands aligned
When you get on the balance ball, it becomes more unstable, and contributes to the train
It would contribute more to the strain
With the unstableness of the balance ball
To eliminate the unstableness, it uses your core, often called the core training, and it helps to strengthen the core
By doing this and having your lower body unstable
It makes something that is already strained, more strained
I don't think it is very good for you
If you use it in core training, then that would be fine
If the pelvis isn't positioned well, and it is opened, then your organs will keep going down
More and more, especially for women, the flow to your lower body will be worse and worse
It is cycle of edema
So, as much as possible, I think it is best to avoid balance balls
I've been doing it for 5 to 6 years
5 to 6 years?
You might have spent 5 to 6 years strengthening your core
But if you don't keep this aligned, in the end
As we mentioned earlier, the foundation is to make the blood flow better, and better the organ's function
The most important is to eliminate the strain of your frame
I think you should go back to using a normal chair
Going back to the training load not being effective,
What you can do is, work on pre trainings before the actual training
Work on the normal frame, but since it is hard to put it back by just posture
For further ways on improving, I can do a one-on-one consultation on that
It might take more than an hour if we do it here
Let's get to the next one on exercises you can do on a daily basis
In everyday life
Of course, it is best to do muscle training and the like but
In your lifestyle, I assume you spend the most time at work
If you can work on the things we talked about today, then that is the best thing you can do
In addition to that, if you have time, then you can work on muscle training and your diet
The fundamental, since working takes up most of your time
If you utilize this time well, then you can continue it for a long time
Training usually takes 30 minutes to 1 hour right?
Since the time you spend at work is longer
It is best to make the most out of this time
More than thinking of running more or training
It is more effective to try and get your lifestyle right, correct your strain for better blood circulation
Are we good?
Now let's look at weight loss in a short period
Who asked this?
Have you tried losing weight in a short amount of time?
I think it is fascinating, but I've heard stories that they rebound after that
I wondered if you had to do it properly whether you had to continue doing it
In short term diets, for example
If you need to lose a certain number by a certain date
Then, you can simply calculate it by tracing back
As I mentioned earlier, diet is about calorie in and calorie out
For example, if you need to lose weight after 10 days, that's a very short time though
If you need to lose 5 kg by then
As we talked about earlier, losing 1 kg of body fat is equivalent to 8000 calories
So, that would be 40,000 calories
If you need to lose 40,000 in this short period
If it's 10 days and you match your goal to that number of days
You will need to account the balance, and you have to burn 40,000 calories in 10 days
How you do this is thru food restriction
For example, if it is very short, food restriction is not enough for burning calories
If it is not enough, the only resort is aerobic exercise
The shorter it gets
The more things you need to do to match the numbers
It may not be enough by simply controlling your diet, or with base metabolism
When you think about this, the short term diet puts on a lot of stress
It puts on a lot stress, so if you ask whether its good or bad
To be honest, it has risks of rebound
If you are able to continue
The restrictions during that short period, then you will be able to maintan it
But because you are doing it in a short period of time, it is very hard
It is hard so, the rebound rate increases too
And, when you lose body fat in a short amount of time
Basically, as the theory goes, when you lose 1 kg of body fat, you also lose 1 kg of muscle
Your body fat burns in a short period
But at the same time, your muscle also reduces
So, what they say about needing to train muscles while dieting is
What they mean is you need to avoid also burning the fat
Another purpose is to put muscle to increase your base metabolism
But it isn't that easy to gain muscle
Especially for women, regardless of how hard they work out, the female hormones come first
They do not get as much muscle
So, when it comes to muscle training during a diet
You have to lose the fat without losing the muscle
This is because of the theory that losing 1 kg of fat will lose 1 kg of muscle
And the priority is to stop this as much as possible
So, when doing this in a short period
Even if the body fat burns at a high speed, the muscle is also lost very quickly
When this happens, when you go back to your old diet
When only the calorie increases, and the muscle stays the same at low level
This becomes the most risky rebound
This is when losing weight in a short period of time
It shows very quickly, so as much as possible
Even if you do it at a fast pace, it should be at least 1 kg a week
The best way is to not put stress on yourself
Try to lose 1 kg to 2 kg in a month
And, ideally, you are able to do this reasonably
I think it depends on that person's body fat too
Is this okay?
Let's talk about the ratio of muscle training and aerobic exercise
It relates to what we talked about earlier but
If your goal is to diet
Putting a little aerobic exercise will not let the figures balance out
If you are not able to lose weight by controlling your diet
You can use aerobic exercises to lose the number up until the goal date
As I mentioned earlier, in an aerobic diet, it is often said that fat will start to burn after 20 minutes
But at the same time, the fat keeps burning
Your muscles are also burning off
Muscles are made out of protein, and this is used as energy
To run and walk
So, as much as possible, for those who want to diet efficiently without rebounds
You should not do aerobic exercises as much as possible
You might often hear people say that running will help you lose weight which is true
But when you continue to run, you will also lose muscles with it
When I was training for the contests I mentioned earlier, I had 2% body fat
I did not do aerobic exercises even once
When the figures didn't match
I would not do aerobic exercises but I would go to a bedrock bath or a sauna to burn off the calories
These aren't aerobic exerises so
I would not lose my muscles
There are those who take BCA as mentioned earlier
When you perform aerobic exercises
Instead of drinking water, there are people who drink VAAM or fat burning suppliments
Other than that, there is also BCAA for muscle energy
There are suppliments to avoid degradation of the muscles, and these may slightly help in prevention
Your muscles cannot be in a catabolic state all the time
It must always be in an anabolic state
If you do this, you will not have to lose muscles
As for the ration, ideally do more muscle training
And lessen the aerobic exercises
Is this okay?
Now, let's get into losing weight while maintaining bulk
That is a very hard core question
In maintaining muscles while still losing weight
As we talked about earlier, when you lose body fat your muscles also reduce, this is the theory
This may get a bit technical but
You have to consume protein in your diet, and this is a fundamental factor
When you lose weight while you maintain bulk
How much protein do you take?
About 3 times
Times 3, you take a lot
You have to at least take that much
At the same time, how do you take your work out drinks during training?
I started with drinking BCA
And, after a little while, I changed to HMB plus EA
That was lot of alphabets
Does is decrease with that?
For the recent contest, I think I was able to maintain it
But I still felt like it went down a little especially around my bottom
I feel like the bulk went down a bit
That means the weight you put on your bottom is not enough
Because you lost fat on it
I was able to keep it up to a certain point, but at the end I went down 3 to 4 centimeters in size
Our muscles are made out of 70% water
It is best not to cut out carbohydrates too much
But, when you do take it calories come in
If the calories pile up, the fat will not come off
So do it moderately
So, in your workout drink during training, do not forget to put carb drinks
Make sure to consume carbs before, during and after training
The fundamental is to include carbohydrates
And, this goes back to our discussion earlier
When you think about carbohydrate restriction, it is not very effective
There are many opinions on this, but that is was I think
But if you do not limit it, it will not come off
You can lose it through diet control
But you have to take carbs before, during, and after your work out
Bulk maintenance is
To put carbs in what is called the golden time where you can work out very hard
What I had a hard time with was
When I train during the day time, I take carbs after and during training
But since I have a day job, I usually train late at night
I usually finish at arounf 10 at night
I get a bit worried about taking carbs during this time
I think that is why I hadn't taken as much carbs at night during training
During training?
Yes, when it is at night
Do you train at night often?
Yes, very often
If that is the case, if your training fits in that schedule it is a must for you to take it
Make sure to take it before, during, and after
Regardless of when you fit your training in, you have to consume it
I think it is common for everyone to want leave as much weight as possible
This is a must
It is less likely that you would gain body fat from it
Is this okay?
Are there any other questions?
Regarding the load of training
For normal people performing muscle training, is there a number of reps?
A minimum and maximum that we should do?
For normal people, in terms of reps, what is standardly being said is
The standard is
You can do as many reps as you want
Is your goal to gain muscle?
If it is to gain muscle, they say that 6 to 10 time is a good number
The logic of setting a number of reps is good
But when you set a number of let's say 6 to 8
Let's say 60 kg benchpress
When you set a goal
You will continue to do it, until you reach it
When you are able to do this, of course your muscle gains
When you try to achieve this goal
You do not pay attention to your form
So, it is best to come up with a certain number of reps you want to do but
What is important is training your chest or your legs the correct way
To put load on the left and right equally
It is good to have an idea of how many reps you will do but
What I do is about 10 reps
With 10 reps, at the beginning I would do 100 kg with 10 reps
On the 2nd set, it will decrease naturally
If it does go down, you do not try too hard to do the same amount of reps
What is the worst you can do is to neglect your form
So, when normal people train
Do 10 reps with a clean form
Do it in a clean form, or if it is hard, do it as many as you can, this is the best way
How about in terms of number of sets?
For normal people, at the beginning 3 sets is a good number
The more you do it, will the effect be less in terms of the effect and the energy?
If you are properly putting the load on the muscles the more you do it, then that is the best
The best is that that muscle comes to a limit and you will reach its maximum capability
If you keep going even if the muscles are all out, then it will have a negative effect
To reach the all out stage, does it mean doing It once or twice has more effect?
We are talking about the form
The best way, they say, is if you can do an all out in 1 set, then 1 set is enough
That needs technique to achieve
To be able to train effectively goes down to the frame and posture we talked about
If your frame is correct, the load on the muscles will go on correctly too
And even 1 set will be very effective
Of course, the bigger the muscles become
The weight becomes heavier and the sets have to be longer to reach the all out state
So, it doesn't mean doing 1 or 2 sets will be most effective to the muscles
Is that okay?
That is all for today, we will be closing this session.
Thank you very much Mr. Uno thank you for coming today.
Thank you.